une définition simple je dirais c'est
simplement un
usage de drogue en contexte sexuel donc
il y a plusieurs contextes d'usage ça
peut être festif c'est quoi en fait
c'est quoi comme drogue alors c'est vrai
qu'il y a des produits un peu plus un
peu spécifiques on va dire à la culture
sexuelle gay dans laquelle est né le
camsexe puisque ça fait 10-12 ans qu'on
parle d'un phénomène quel sexe comme ça
moi je pense que c'est aussi lié à une
culture sexuelle et effectivement il y a
des produits qui sont plutôt comment
dire liés à cette culture donc je pense
à au catinon je pense
que vous parlez là
on parle de la 3
langages plus courant non pas
d'autoroute non mais
c'est enfin voilà il y a différents noms
pour différents produits on parle
beaucoup du GHB aussi par exemple qui
peut être aussi utilisé un contexte
sexuel voilà enfin par exemple c'est
quoi ces soirées parce que il paraît des
heures et des heures
ça peut être ça peut être ça mais ça
dépend il y a toutes sortes de
situations on veut savoir en fait quoi
qu'est-ce que je fais sexuellement
pour les hommes ça permet d'avoir la
Gaule bien merci
Astérix ça dépend vraiment du produit
pour le coup et je pense que c'est pas
le temps une question d'érection c'est
plutôt une question de
désinhibition des inhibitions de
comment dire des soirées comme ça oui ça
c'est quoi comment s'appelle on dit
ouais on va se droguer par exemple dans
la culture hétéro les gens ils vont
boire un verre de vin il va
éventuellement fumer un pétard bah nous
on va pas se faire une ligne de 3 par
exemple ça peut être que l'abus d'alcool
est dangereux pour la santé aussi il a
but de drogue aussi
si vous faites ça comme ça tranquille
bah écoutez moi je pense qu'il faut pas
stigmatiser l'usage de drogue je pense
que
voilà parce que vous dites ça maintenant
on en reparlera dans quelques années
vous allez voir vous avez vu ce qui est
arrivé à Pierre Palmade justement
parce que je pense que cette cette c'est
à cause de la prohibition et de la
stigmatisation quand on arrive à des
responsabiliser ensuite les
comportements à l'envers pour l'alcool
pour l'alcool justement il y a des
campagnes de prévention il y a des
messages de prévention par rapport à au
fait de pas conduire sous-état sous
emprise d'un produit pour quand il
s'agit des autres produits qui sont
illégaux on n'a pas ce discours sur le
bon usage sur les réduction des risques
ça c'est pas se mettre à l'envers et
après après voilà prendre la voiture et
mettre en danger la vie d'autrui
dans un cas de festif vous preniez
certains produits mais là dans quel sexe
mettanthétamine kétamine cocaïne mais
c'est quoi on dirait que c'est des
produits qu'on prend pour se stimuler et
ses produits là sont totalement illégaux
c'est-à-dire que c'est pas des produits
qu'on peut prendre dans un cas de festif
c'est pas du Cacolac quoi c'est illégal
donc monsieur vous pouvez pas faire
l'apologie de la prise de drogue
il faut arrêter de stigmatiser l'usage
de drogue parce que on arrive avec des
situations et des drames comme celui-là
où responsabilise les gens en fait c'est
à dire que moi je pense que si on va
avoir une approche de réduction des
risques qui soient efficace il faut
arrêter avec les condamnations morales
parce que là on a des personnes comme
enfin moi je suis pas pour défendre
monsieur Palma dans particuliers mais ça
fait des années des années que les gens
savent qu'il a des problèmes de
consommation c'est quelqu'un qui est
complètement isolé sur ce problème là
personne va l'aider apparemment et on
arrive à ce genre de situation là moi je
pense que quand les gens se disent bon
interdit pour interdit du coup ils font
n'importe quoi effectivement on prend
une voiture alors que si on avait un
message clair par exemple sur l'alcool
c'est un produit qui est très dangereux
en réalité l'alcool mais on a une
culture d'usage de l'alcool c'est à dire
qu'on sait par exemple comment il y a
des vers différents selon la méthode on
va passer quand on boit une conduit pas
de la drogue on ne conduit pour mettre
en danger d'accord
n'existent pas parce que le seul message
qui existe c'est c'est de la merde c'est
pas bien nanana et donc on est juste
dans une condamnation morale on cherche
pas à comprendre les gens et à essayer
justement de les responsabiliser par
rapport à leur comportement alors il
paraît que même sur des applications on
propose des soirées fait très attention
je vous le dis n'allez pas ça vraiment
c'est le début des emmerdes oui Sophie
il y a un bouquin que j'ai lu il y a
quelques
temps et qui parle de ça de ces
pratiques sexuelles et c'est en fait
cet auteur justement il raconte un peu
les bas-fonds parisiens et cetera les
nuits parisiennes et entre autres les
soirées qui aime sexe auxquelles il a
participé et en fait il y a quand même
beaucoup de soirée je sais pas si vous
avez assisté à ce genre de choses mais
au domicile par exemple de certaines
personnes et en fait elles sont souvent
filmées souvent à plusieurs et souvent
en fait la pièce dans laquelle ça se
passe c'est bâché en fait donc il se
passe des trucs très très trashs bâché
avec des bâches en plastique pour voilà
pour éviter les dans ces traces ici
donc il y a c'est que des en fait c'est
que des molécules chimiques qui sont
mélangées les unes aux autres vous
m'arrêter si je dis n'importe quoi mais
enfin en tout cas c'est ce qui racontait
dans le bouquin moi je les ai pas vécu
mais lui il les a vécu et il est relate
dans ce livre et voilà c'est des
molécules chimiques sur miaule et
chimiques c'est que des mélanges ça peut
durer parfois des heures ou des jours
entiers et c'est tracissime quoi en fait
on fait pas ça par hasard vous faites
pas ça juste pour faire durer le plaisir
plus longtemps parce que qui explique en
plus que non seulement enfin oui on
bande pendant des heures etc c'est bon
ça se dilate de partout et en plus de ça
il y a pas d'orgasme c'est un orgasme et
retardé dans les détails vous me
demandez d'écrire les soirées on dit que
les gens qui pratiquent le camsexe sont
souvent des gens qui ont du mal à
assumer leur sexualité donc parfois des
hétéros qui se cachent même qui sont
homosexuels ou des gens qui aiment
certaines pratiques mais qui ont besoin
d'être dans un état second pour les
pratiquer justement est-ce que c'est
vrai
je ne pense pas enfin moi je pense que
il faut éviter de généraliser là parce
que là j'entends plein de choses et en
fait je pense qu'il y a tout type de
situation qui existe en réalité je pense
qu'il y a aussi des hétérosexuels qui
consomment des drogues en contexte
sexuel sauf que on n'a pas utilisé de
terme pour ça et que moi j'ai
l'impression que on est en train de
fantasmer de faire des projections sur
la vie sexuelle des gens mais en fait
c'est quelque chose enfin l'usage de
drogue ça existe depuis la nuit des
temps en fait là on va on va on va on a
on a la chance d'avoir une lettre que
vos ici Daniel
non mais je peux enfin on peut pas
laisser dire ça c'est le Washington Post
a dit que quand même le cinquième siècle
c'est le sida numéro 2 et c'est très
très dangereux
parce qu'il y a quand même il le sida
c'est quand même une histoire très
traumatisante pour notre communauté là
je bouge de plus en plus à réfléchir
quand même en disant c'est très
dangereux pour les participants aussi là
malheureusement celle-ci ça a été quand
même 40 000 morts hein
le mari
de Jean-Marie est mort pendant une cam
sex parce que en plus évidemment quand
il y a un gros problème ces gens-là
n'osent pas appeler peut-être la police
soit par contre soit par peur donc ils
peuvent mourir sur place et ce qui est
arrivé au mari de Jean-Luc Romero donc
quand vous nous expliquer qu'il faut pas
stigmatiser je ne sais quoi c'est des
jolis mots mais voilà la réalité c'est
ça et les gens sont très inquiets le
phénomène qui prend de l'ampleur qui
était hétéro pardon homo au départ qui
est né en Grande-Bretagne mais qui était
très encadré parce que justement on
connaît les dangers de ces pratiques là
maintenant c'est vraiment n'importe
quand n'importe quoi n'importe où avec
n'importe qui ça de ça gagne sur les
hétéros et c'est très très inquiète en
fait
stigmatiser c'est autre chose je
voudrais vraiment dire ce que vous venez
de dire parce qu'en vous dites les
personnes se sont enfui dans ce dans ce
contexte là et parce qu'ils ont paniqué
moi je pense que c'est le résultat d'un
contexte actuel qui le contexte de la
prohibition parce qu'effectivement les
gens ils paniquent parce qu'ils ont peur
parce qu'ils se disent si j'appelle les
Samus ou quoi que ce soit il y a les
flics qui vont débarquer je vais risquer
mais je suis criminalisé mais donc
après la drogue est interdite oui c'est
quand même
à cause de la prohibition non j'ai dit
que c'est à cause de la prohibition que
les gens paniquent et au lieu d'appeler
le secours il s'enfuit exactement
mais pourquoi parce que les gens ne ne
peuvent pas en fait la prohibition bien
sûr que c'est à cause de la prohibition
moi ce que je veux dire est-ce qu'il
m'intéresse dans ce que ce garçon a dit
c'est c'est une autre génération la
mienne c'était de l'alcool dans les
soirées tout ça ça n'existait pas tout
ça ce qui est intéressant ce que vous
dites c'est que oui on connaît pas quand
tu dis effectivement tu bois de l'alcool
tu sais les effets et donc tu sais
pourquoi tu dois pas boire tu prends une
drogue tu as dit qui était kétamine
personne sait ce que c'est donc qui
prend ça peut-être qui sait pas que
derrière il peut pas conduire donc je
pense que il faut
je pense qu'il faut au moins informé
aujourd'hui les gens sur ces dangers sur
ces choses parce que là on parle de
choses personne c'est ce que c'est
personne ne sait rien ben donc les mots
comment veux-tu que c'est ça exactement
et en termes de service après-vente
pardon mais lequel sexe malgré tout
c'est très très risqué il faut que vous
le disiez en fait à ce qui nous
regardent parce que vous vous pratiquez
c'est très risqué il y a une explosion
de l'hépatite C à cause des risques à
cause des plaies à cause des abcès il y
a une explosion des quatre VIH c'est
c'est dans toutes les les publications
aujourd'hui à San Francisco et tout ça
si vous voulez avoir c'est très très
dangereux c'est pas anodin c'est pas
banal c'est pas drôle c'est pas si vous
voulez avoir une action de santé
efficace et que les personnes vous
écoutent je pense qu'il vaut mieux
éviter d'être dans une condamnation mais
plutôt justement écouter le ce que les
personnes ont à dire dans leur pratique
dans leurs usages plutôt que de passer
merci
de vous dire vous les hétéros vous avez
vraiment des des vraiment des
irresponsables à boire de l'alcool et à
vous tuer sur la route ça fait des
milliers de morts sur la route chaque
année on a toujours dit non la seule
différence c'est que il y en a un qui
est légal et l'autre qui est légal
bouder c'est tout là j'ai remarqué que
tous les gens que ça soit là-bas ils
sont énervés
[Rires]
une raison en fait merci en tout cas
d'avoir été là
visage découvert en tout cas